Thank you very, very much.
Oh gosh.
It is, it's wonderful to be here.
I was actually just in New York.
You ever hail a cab just to
stop it from hitting you?
(audience laughs)
Never know what to tip those guys.
Big week in my apartment
building this week.
Very big week.
The phone book arrived.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, thank god.
I don't know how I was getting
by without the phone book.
(audience laughs)
Open the door, it was staring
up at me from the floor like,
here, we printed a portion of the internet
for you to throw away.
(audience laughs)
It's a lot of fun to tell jokes.
I'm just so glad I'm not a magician.
(audience laughs)
Have you taken a moment today
to be grateful that you're not a magician?
(audience laughs)
There's so much pressure.
Comedy audiences come
out to have a good time.
Magic is the only kind of entertainment
where 90% of the crowd is trying
to ruin it for themselves.
(audience laughs)
Go to a magic show just to see
if close-minded threatened
dudes just like, nope.
(audience laughs)
No way, that ain't possible.
Mirror.
(audience laughs)
Some sort of mirror.
You ain't sawing her in half.
(audience laughs)
Like, yeah you did it.
You proved what none of
us were trying to prove.
(audience laughs)
The boy onstage is not actually a wizard.
And it's always dudes who,
mirror, no, no way.
Girls are into it.
They're like, there is something more.
(audience laughs)
That's how you should be.
That's how I am, I love magic.
Look at my friendly open face.
(audience laughs)
I sit in the front row, do I volunteer?
You're damn right I volunteer.
(audience laughs)
A magician drops his fake thumb,
I didn't see nothin', I wanna believe.
(audience laughs)
I live in a non-magic world all day.
Make it magic.
(audience laughs)
I was at a show recently
where I saw a man fly.
Listen to me.
I didn't misspeak.
A man, a wingless mammal took flight.
(audience laughs)
You're not thinking,
imagine if I flew right now.
(audience laughs)
If I could figure out
the muscle in my butt
that I need to flex, it's
working, and I just took off.
(audience laughs)
And I flew above the audience,
picked some of you up
with me, we flew around.
(audience laughs)
Best night of our lives.
And I saw this.
And suddenly, I'm eight again
and I'm filled with majesty.
And a guy next to me,
I don't know this guy,
who's this guy?
Leans over me and goes, it's a magnet.
(audience laughs)
Magnet, he can't fly, magnet.
First of all, shut your
mouth and enjoy the show.
Second of all, that explains nothing.
(audience laughs)
What does that mean?
He stuffs his pocket with magnets?
The stage is a magnet?
That would look terrible.
(audience laughs)
I think those are just two
things he doesn't understand.
(audience laughs)
Like, I don't get magnets
and I don't get this.
(audience laughs)
This is magnets.
One time I had two pieces of
metal, they wouldn't touch,
then I flipped one, then they would.
That's how he flies.
(audience laughs)
Must be very frustrating
too for the magician
'cause there's no noise to make
when you see a magic
trick for the audience.
With comedy, it's very rewarding
'cause there's a built-in
biological response,
which is laughter.
But with magic there's nothing.
You can see the best trick in the world,
whatever noise you make
sounds condescending and fake.
(audience laughs)
He can be like, okay
Pete what was you card?
You can tell me.
Tell us now, what was your card?
It was the three of clubs, okay yeah.
And you signed it?
Is that right, you signed it?
Yeah, okay.
And then you put it in this
barrel of fire, is that correct?
(audience laughs)
We all watched as you placed
it in a barrel of fire, yeah.
And the whole time I was blindfolded,
upside down in a tank of
water, is that correct?
(audience laughs)
Yeah, it's back, three of clubs.
And now it's all on you and
you just have to be like ooh.
(audience laughs)
How?
Not what I expected.
(audience laughs)
It must suck.
I bet it's the dream of
every magician in the world
that there would be some sort of
involuntary knee-jerk
response to seeing magic.
That they would be like,
the tiger was over here.
(air blows)
Voila, it's over here.
And people would just be like,
(Pete screams)
(audience laughs)
Oh magic.
(audience claps)
I love your magic.
You don't wanna make this noise,
you have to make this noise.
(Pete screams)
(audience laughs)
Then there are people that
don't quite get the trick,
but they fake it.
They're like, oh yeah.
(Pete moans)
(audience laughs)
Magic.
Oh the tiger moved.
(Pete mumbles)
Thank you very, very much everybody.
(audience cheers)
You have a great night, appreciate it.